[Music]
oh---but my name is and I'm here with
anime man
yeah that's my name and now we're gonna
watch them any man no damn dog have you
done this
no so you don't know what this is no but
I can kind of guess from what just it's
a competition I'm sorry okay whoever
wins is the king of animation
it seems fair yeah that's that makes
sense
okay so the point of this game is that
it will show a random picture from vici
Howard right yeah weak yeah they always
have those strange out of context like
that yeah a lot of that like that and we
have to guess which one it's for and
we'll keep score and the one that wins
is the king of anything because we all
know the king of anime can find every
wikiHow article that exists on the
internet it seems fair yeah and the
loser is the king of hentai I think I'd
rather be a woman moving on
alright how - okay so that's shaggy and
a cat with a monster he's shaggy it's
like a cleanly shaved shaggy
oh wait or is that a clue what do you
mean okay sure he looks like a drunk oh
we're not in this picture don't diss my
boy Shang I'm gonna see what we have
some options that we have so much how
would you have an imaginary boyfriend or
a girlfriend
mmm what does that mean it means how to
so how does that really here it's
basically how to satisfy yourself with a
cat into the cat with a mustache I may
not be very invested in that to be fair
alright this is why you're the hand
tanking already how to be interesting
don't be PewDiePie
we were having a good time
this is being real with you why don't
you respond to sarcasm clearly I need to
know how to act like one of the guys
what have we got like FTB for the boys
what that's the thing we used to say in
Australia boys we're not in Australia
now tits out for the boys
yeah okay well clearly it's not how to
respond to okay uh actually could be I
have my guest
really yeah what how does Shaggy have to
do with any of this
I don't think it's shaggy that is shaggy
I'm sticking with Shire
I'm gonna say okay but you have to say
it okay I think it's how to respond the
sarcasm okay good because I think it's
how to be interesting
really yeah something you don't know
anything about I said the joke first go
yeah this is bored by the uninteresting
mess just take it you lost oh my god you
suck link Oh any man okay well that's
all right cuz I'd rather be the king
oh how to be a good honest Big Sur that
what is happening how to make your own
death mask how does how to how to escape
your own body exactly how to support the
Earth's alright that was kind of what
you were saying he kinda had a channel
how do you have fun with that friends is
it working
Scott how to make someone feel better
via text message is the one yeah cuz
when you get that right text you just
escaped from that relatable moment when
you just get the best take that hey was
for wise it's just bought a experience
that's how to channel mean how to
channel what like she like thinks is
doing the opposite of that right now
how to support the arts that could can
apply to anything well that's the point
of the game okay I'm picking how to
check I'm gonna say how to channel as
well channel know correct answers how to
have fun without friends what weight is
the face the friend that does this like
a really like oxy way of saying just
look in the mirror no anyone gets that
right no well clearly if they did they
clearly have fun without ya all right
next one ah-ha how do get the monetize
yeah how to get a colonoscopy how to
Sidhu how to smell seductive um ticket
smell is seductive why would you make
that is the smell coming from the
butthole is that why she's like how to
perform a lap dance for your boyfriend
or husband well clearly she's doing it
wrong in that case no that was right you
lay down on the carpet floor thanks
events for your butt cheek how to
identify serving key chest how to have
Jehovah's Witnesses go away that is
about phasing down that face will deftly
do it I think it's lip service so the
thing I can't pronounces so this I don't
know how to friends any visit us you go
with that one yeah I think I'll go in
[Music]
you can't be how to perform a lap dance
if it is I'm reading this on well it has
to be this one oh can we look at what's
abusive disses how do we get that right
well because I just guess because it
kind of sounds like cervix Oh
don't Google service do not do I kind of
need to see it again just to know what I
saw I don't I need to see it again just
so I can forget you know like look like
stop stop it looks like the alien coming
out of them
let's just move on let's just move on
let's forget about it
this never happened we're okay this is
us right now yeah that's me on the right
be like what the [ __ ] okay why not it
tungsten yeah also why does the woman
look like a man if you don't know that's
a strong jawline for a woman that is a
strong jawline how to know your warning
signs before becoming abusive where
where the two of those
this is 50/50 what this is correct
warning signs because more becoming
abusive
that's all you do yeah you just you just
do one of these give him one of ours
that's how I started my channel how's it
go how to be laid-back I mean it's not
okay I think it it's had warning signs
because I think the sign here is that
he's drunk
oh is that what it is but which one I'll
play I'll click this one but nice here
yeah he's not you at all
god damn what's the school we I think
we're equal okay okay this is so intense
I really want it okay panting I'm honest
or is it I'm honest it's Iman Iman is it
simplest or it's lying on its impo nest
how to become an alpha male I don't
think that's the share you want to wear
no not to know if you're
don't you love yourself I hope to
perform a lap dance why does that one
keep up here I think how do they love
you I think it's how to love yourself
too I should we just go then ah oh man
does that mean we're not alpha man we're
clearly beta as well a bunch of babe
yeah we're not honest that means what
beta Oh how to that is that a vial of
blood with five spoons
well you never spice lose my baby five
spoons
is that how to play the spoons police
say that's one of the options how to
play bridge what's that all the card
game oh is that the one I feel like
that's so that has to be it because
that's how they use it I'm told all the
time that's how you know five spoons the
whole five spoon trick I don't want that
someone pouring their period of a five
spoon okay up that's how I feel right
now how to make a thumbnail that would
actually be a good thumbnail she would
do that how to lose your fear of beam
flying that seems about right
get partners like please don't fire me
how to get along with you'll crush okay
yo cross you're gonna love that how to
understand gay and lesbian people I like
how that's a actual article that they
wrote as well yeah like it's not how to
make yourself oh that's clearly not it
because if we we would have peed out so
we're ready to the home just the sports
just be happy I reckon it is how to get
along with your crush I think so too you
have you have to just fake it yeah what
is this saying about us Joey what does
this say about us
this is what does this mean I need to
see this article where is the face oh
there it is wait baby please make it
that's horrible
what the hell does that mean it means
even if you don't like them just pretend
you like them but that's [ __ ] I'm
gonna say something like how to give
back it reminds me over in Sims when you
have to talk to the mirror to increase
your charisma it could be so how do how
to speeches yeah how to impersonate
Nickelback how to get on a materiality
TV show that could be it had a fun
without friends or she's clearly
enjoying us what we already had that one
do me how to tell if someone is high you
know if they're willing afraid how to
make people think you're a witch I'm
gonna say how to have fun without
friends is that your final answer or you
know to on saw
I have to change my channel now for the
handyman I'm sorry I'm sorry guys I'm so
so I'm glad we got this Sam here once
and for all
have fun being demonetised forever yeah
I know if that already wasn't a problem
yeah okay first of all how does what
does that have to do with anything
it's wikiHow if you can't explain it
then you can get the point
boy she's practicing to be from the
frame of a television how are you laughs
that wheelie makes it useful man how
they redid before ah doesn't get allowed
come on it doesn't come on well I guess
we'll have to do part two in another
year yearly for the anime Olympics all
right hope you guys enjoyed this video
check out Joey's channel called the
hentai let's pull the hands I'm in now
so if you want good quality hand I come
to you boy anime out Janet tuber
simulator it's now so relevant that it's
got a brand new mini game cranium drop
the crane and get fresh items only
available in the washing machine like
game and you say there's more of course
there is new knowledge perks new quests
and new pics links and links guys lake